con un tono casi de ruego el presidente
en su pedido de paralizar la Reforma
judicial tras una noche de masivas
manifestaciones y en medio de otra
jornada de protestas y huelgas gerson
alertó sobre los riesgos en la seguridad
la economía y la sociedad y pidió una
vez más al gobierno de netanyahu frenar
la legislación y al resto de los
partidos políticos ser responsables y
sentarse a dialogar Y es que la crisis
ha alcanzado una dimensión sin
precedentes con el despido del ministro
de defensa Job galán luego de que
reclamara suspender la reforma también
alegando motivos de seguridad para
muchos israelíes fue un punto de no
retorno y a las protestas espontáneas de
anoche se ha sumado hoy una huelga que
va desde trabajadores de la salud de la
educación y de la alta tecnología hasta
los trabajadores de puertos y
aeropuertos Incluso se sumó la principal
central Obrera que hasta el momento se
había mantenido al margen de las
protestas su líder Arnold David asegu ró
que es necesario parar con esta locura
aún con toda esta presión el comité
legal de la kennecet continúan
reuniéndose aprobó el proyecto de ley
que da mayoría al gobierno en la
elección de jueces para que pase sus
últimas dos lecturas en el pleno esto
muestra que los socios de extrema
derecha de netanyahu están decididos a
seguir adelante y el Primer Ministro
intenta convencerlos de no dejar caer el
gobierno si se paraliza la legislación